let me tell you a little story about
backwards politics or the bizarro world
or call it what you want
president Trump throws government hiring
earlier this week and there was this
campaign promise under the guise of
saving money and reducing the deficit
that he would indeed do this he would
freeze all new federal hiring this is so
transparently ridiculous and I'm going
to explain to you why sometimes people
have to be hired because work needs to
get done and work is still going to need
to get done by all sorts of federal
agencies if you have a federal hiring
freeze how do you get the work done well
there's two ways number one you start
paying overtime to existing employees
which is very very expensive or number
two even more expensive and even more
common you start hiring contractors and
consultants from outside companies to do
the work who charge way more than
government salaries if I replace federal
workers with contractors I can
accurately say I've reduced spending on
federal wages or at least I've not
increased spending on federal wages I
might save a million dollars in federal
wages but if I have to spend 1.2 million
dollars on contractors to replace the
million dollars saved on federal wages
I'm increasing total spending I'd still
be sticking by my campaign promise of
reducing or limiting spending on federal
wages but I'm not actually saving
taxpayers money in fact it's quite the
opposite and we have examples to look at
have passed federal hiring freeze has
been good policy have they been good
economically or in any other ways
shocker no they haven't been democratic
President Jimmy Carter and Republican
President Ronald Reagan both did similar
hiring freezes the Government
Accountability Office examined them and
they determined I know this might be
shocking to some of you that they don't
work hiring freezes quote have little
effect on federal employment levels the
report from the GAO added that these
freezes quote disrupt agency operations
and in some cases increased costs to the
government also just think about it from
a completely common sense perspective
you've you've got employees and there's
more work than they can handle you can't
hire new people because of a federal
hiring hiring freeze so you bring in
outside contractors to help with the
work outside contractors aren't familiar
with the organization and with the
day-to-day processes etc and they can
actually disrupt the the work that is
being done in a way that ends up costing
even more money to get back to working
order it's all backwards and of course
never far behind with the Trump
administration Pat is the reality that
the hiring freeze also will
disproportionately affect women
minorities and veterans since they
represent a higher share of federal
employees than the private sector
save money by enacting expensive
policies what this is really just one of
those Republican tactics that they
always go back to they pretend that
they're going to either create jobs or
save money and it turns out that the
bill is actually counterproductive to
those goals and really it's about just
playing into corporate interests it's
also sort of a distraction because
there's not been a big increase in
federal employment I know that the right
likes to think that government is
completely out of control in terms of
hiring and hiring check out this graph
which shows the federal civilian
workforce as a share of total civilian
non-farm workforce it's basically been
on a steady decline since it peaked
shortly after at the end of World War
two this just isn't even an issue even
though Trump press secretary Sean Spicer
has lied about that as well saying
there's been a quote dramatic expansion
of the federal workforce
this is policies that do the opposite of
what they're supposed to do based on
lies about what the problems even are
that's kind of a slogan I guess for the
Trump administration solutions that
don't work the problems that don't exist
that should be a bumper sticker or
something I kind of like that Gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can
by them for a low used price there's
never any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s